hey guys it's God's Xavier here with
another Xavier vide this coming year
they'll be filming a Mortal Kombat movie
for the first time in almost 20 years
this is a big deal because Mortal Kombat
hasn't branched out from video games in
a substantial way in almost 20 years but
at one point in time it was a
blockbuster mega franchise a time the
world for the most part seems to have
forgotten after becoming one of the most
famous and infamous games of all time
Mortal Kombat in the 90s felt like prime
real estate for a cross-media franchise
that would take pop-culture by storm
unfortunately though I have a pretty
strong feeling that across the entire
decade every non gaming usage of the
Mortal Kombat brand suffered from one
fundamental flaw they have no idea what
the hell makes Mortal Kombat good with
the controversy and outrage surrounding
the level of violence in the games
themselves pretty much everything
attached to the brand tried to combat
this negative press by painting the
series in a new light
or changing its target audience or just
outright ignoring that the game was ever
bloody to begin with because I'm a
spider-man comic book channel I say we
take a look at the comics first since
they're relatively simple this first
issue from 1992 serves as a nice little
primer for the story of the games and
tries to help you get introduced to the
cast of characters Buster drawn by the
guy that we talked about in the other
video it's kind of funny how many
different interpretations of Mortal
Kombat use this plot point of the
characters going to Shang Fang Foom
xylan Don a boat and having a brief
altercation on the way there although
there's some inconsistencies that I've
always wondered about like how Kano has
a beard and hair again or raiden raiden
it's a neat setup but it's just got one
problem there's not a drop of blood to
be found anywhere I'm not expecting it
to be Luther strode but for comics in
the 90s meant to be a little edgier this
feels almost like a tie-in issue for a
Saturday morning cartoon which is a
weird bit of foreshadowing this comic
would lead into being the base for the
first couple of minutes of the Mortal
Kombat movie that would hit theaters on
August 18 1995 video game movies were
still relatively new at the time and
hadn't been around long enough to
establish themselves as consistently
terrible and consistently terrible as a
great segue into introduced
the director of this film Paul WS
Anderson I'm going to my trailer move on
after this project to ruin another
beloved franchise of games except he
really didn't let up on that one Jesus
can you imagine if we lived in an
alternate timeline where we just got six
of these movies instead but as it is I
wouldn't say this movie ruined Mortal
Kombat per se just didn't do it full
justice saw I'm a criminal oh you think
you slick
just get out my face [ __ ] ain't that a
shame you've been knocked out the game
so the intro is pretty similar to that
tie-in comic with one major difference
being that Scorpion and sub-zero rivalry
has been changed and they're more or
less just two generic henchman for Shang
Tsung school bean and so zoom deadliest
of enemies but slaves they also try to
make Liu Kang less boring as a character
by giving him a tragic backstory where
his younger brother gets soul sucked by
shang-chi Kang is now more like a
reluctant hero who doesn't want to be a
Bruce Lee badass because not wanting to
be cool and strong is totally a
compelling character art I love what the
main character needs to be convinced by
six or seven other people to get
anything done Johnny Cage and selling
are kind of kind of perfect honestly
like even the games write them and have
them acted out about the same way I
can't tell if that's the movie being
accurate to the vision of the people
behind the game or the games being
influenced by their adaptation and okay
know didn't have this accent until after
the movie that's for sure I'll start it
a little movie I think this movie also
influenced the idea of Raiden being kind
of like a kindly father figure to the
rest of the heroes instead of just some
angry combat man that's remained pretty
consistent throughout the games after
this though they didn't really keep his
sense of humor
the fate of billions will depend upon
you
sorry he was a unique mentor character
and that he's kind of a smartass and
pokes fun at the heroes while guiding
them but later he's just Gandalf you
obviously one lonely [ __ ] huh hey just
say nothing person I got to lift weights
cuz I find like him and I'll use roids
either can't believe this [ __ ]
oh you obviously don't know who I am I
must be slipping get Jack Bob Buster
like you see you so I hope even though
the characters are hit or miss the
movie's plot feels pretty on point for
how Mortal Kombat movie would go it
introduces all the right ideas and
structures the plot well enough to give
everyone a decent fight scene safer
Raiden the only thing holding it back is
just how easy it is and not in like a
fun campy way it wants you to take these
things seriously that are completely
laughable like these bad CGI models or
this slow and clunky animatronic for
Goro or this badly written dialogue it's
all just poorly implemented and I can't
tell if it was them thinking it would be
really fun regardless or if they just
didn't care that much and figured the
brand would make Bank no matter how hard
they tried in some areas the fight
scenes are serviceable for a 90s action
movie I guess you can see what's
happening they even make an attempt to
cap off the fights with a kind of brutal
finisher move I think the sound design
does wonders for these scenes because it
gives it so much extra impact and wait
[Applause]
only thing I don't like is when they go
a little too hard on slow motion for
stuff that really didn't need to be in
slow motion plus did they need to make
weird changes like reptile being a
demon-possessed statue or scorpion spear
being a snake that lives in his arm at
least he is voiced by Ed Boon from the
game so he sounds perfect why Shane
young so son right off the bat wait a
second spite of that this actor for him
is just a blast he's the perfect amount
of cheesy where he's chewing the scenery
but he's still kind of badass anyway
he's the most moral combat guy here for
as little as he is in the movie with
everyone else I think they just didn't
show the villains the same amount of
love and care as they did with the
heroes there's any real saving grace
it's this high-pass soundtrack we got
metal we got techno dance music we got
Tracy Lords I guess have fun googling
that kids we got the theme song that's
so good we're using it 24 years later
imagine being this guy Sub Zero being
introduced in a suit and tie and
sunglasses in this comic and then going
whoops let me change into my sky blue
ninja suit during a helicopter ride is
by far the funniest [ __ ] overall it's
not a completely terrible movie
especially considering the usual caliber
of video game movies in general there
are parts that I think are pretty neat
other stuff I just find tolerable but
there's still a substantial amount of
flaws that keep it from being as good as
it could have been and once again almost
no blood I can't wait to see the next
installment of the epic combat saga
hopefully something with better CG
animation
so remember how I was talking about that
boat ride they took to the island in
that comic and in the movie well this is
just like a whole animated film about
that pretty much you not did yet keep it
that way
I get lost it was during that awkward
transitional period for animation where
we had the ability to use CGI but we
didn't have um the ability I think Toy
Story came out a little later that same
year so it was really just down to
budget and respect for the craft if you
put a lot of time money and effort into
it you can make something cool despite
your technical limitations but this
movie didn't have the money time or
effort it's a goddamn mess the CGI
animation needs nothing to be said about
it but let's try these models all have
ball joints where the limbs clip into
each other and then the faces aren't
capable of a moding on top of that they
all seem to have one open hand and one
clenched further cementing the aesthetic
as those action figures you could get at
the dollar store that weren't officially
licensed in your grandma gave them to
you as a Christmas present because you
didn't actually tell her what you were
interested in that year so she just kind
of figured it out and was like yeah I
maybe I'll like this and then you're
like aw come on grandma you know you
didn't want to tell her that you were
super disappointed so you just kind of
like oh cool whatever but but you didn't
like it I can assume from the movement
that they motion captured this which is
kind of impressive for the time I
suppose but like the person wasn't wide
enough to fit Goro's frame so his
shoulders are really contracted in on
the model and his lower arms just sort
of dangle because they were animated by
hand if the technology isn't good enough
yet to do something how about like not
try to do it the Lin Kuei had been fully
cyber eyes the Lin Kuei the 2d animation
is just sort of lazy I noticed it has no
sense of blocking the character switch
place isn't a scene every time the
camera cuts to a new angle so it's hard
to get an idea of where they're standing
or what's really going on they break the
180-degree line in the
fight scenes every time someone doesn't
move the characters never feel like they
fit in the environment they're in
because it's just ugly CGI backdrops
that are superimposed over they feel
like green screen effects floating on
screen shots of a 90s PC game
they also cheaped out and reuse the same
animations over and over and over and
over as far as I can tell they did the
character art in 2d than chroma keyed it
in but they realized it looked a little
um not even remotely a part of these
backgrounds so they turned up the blur
effect on the edges hoping it would make
it blend together the result is everyone
has this gross muddy outline around them
that's more distracting than immersive
Shyne song are these character designs
did this guy just never skip leg day
also why does he look like a king of the
hill character what's this guy smiling
about the only good thing about this is
that they lease got some decent voice
actors like the terror mask for dang-son
scorpion to secure a place in the
hallowed Victory all of your clan you
must kill the sub-zero yourself or
Commander Shepard is Sonia Tennant Sonya
Blade Special Forces we got a tip a
wanted man was going to be on the ship
well that's kind of funny in retrospect
and in a stroke of the best casting ever
Johnny Bravo is Johnny Cage I'm Johnny
Cage the film actor for some reason
every time I hear Jeff Bennett's voice I
can only imagine all the times he
screamed as various characters it seems
like this is just a poorly put together
crash course on some of the basics of
the game's lore you know just to get you
caught up on who everyone is and what
they're doing
except for Kano because for some reason
he's not there I just don't see a lot of
heart or passion being put into this and
again it's so weird to have yet another
Mortal Kombat project without a hint of
violence let's shift gears to at least
one Mortal Kombat peripheral experience
that allowed for someone to actually
like die in the 90s I think the only non
gaming Mortal Kombat thing that didn't
censor five seconds of glorious Gore was
this obscure British gaming show they
had the game actors for Sonya and Johnny
appear in costume in character and
battle in a version of the game where
they kept the violence my money the
Super Nintendo version there's to go
study but a gameplay but the mega drive
versions got all the death moves and all
the blood Sonya just spam the same move
over and over and then fatality his ass
and Daniel pasina's disappointment is
palpable look at him he's a broken man
this was his shining moment it was
stolen away from him from this point
forward he plotted his eternal revenge
not just on Elizabeth maliki but on the
world
have you ever felt a chill down your
spine and a cold hands clamped down on
your neck that's him turning his dark
attentions on your mortal soul from his
curse at sky fortress anyway this was a
fun little side thing I just wanted to
call attention to I needed a slight
palate cleanser before it gets worse
okay so what do you do with the
bloodiest video game ever created now
that it's a pop-culture phenomenon in a
media point of major contention same
thing we did with Robocop and Rambo make
it a kids cartoon you remember the hit
kids toy line aliens
well now we got Mortal Kombat figures
with non spine ripping action Jesus [ __ ]
Mortal Kombat defenders the realm is the
1996 crime against humanity that lasted
a very turbulent 13 episodes it's hard
to believe this show is real it's every
bad cliche about our Saturday morning
cartoon that exists
it's like a parody like that Saturday
morning watchman video that Alan Moore
said he likes right down to the pet
sidekick added for toys the playset
friendly command center where all the
characters live or the quotable
battlecry Sonya says it every single
time
sonia maintain your current position
it's strategically wrong and it exists
in a weird continuity where the Mortal
Kombat movie happened prior to this
series except like even last bloody
they call back to it a lot because they
were under the insane delusion that this
movie was a big hit with the kids and
brand synergy was important they've been
doing this [ __ ] forever the show's plot
is pretty heavily derived from Mortal
Kombat 3 where Shao Kahn and every other
d-bag from the multiverse invades earth
via portals to take it over except in
this case all the bad guys do it like
one at a time so we can have an episode
about each the combatants are now an
elite squad who sit around in a
technology encrusted cave all day
waiting for portals to open so they can
go curb-stomp whoever stepped through
them and tell them to stay in their
dimensional Lane first major problem
with that is this looks nothing like
earth and I have no idea where the hell
they are at any given time the whole
show takes place in a desert we're on a
beach or some old ruins or a cave they
rarely ever show any civilization and
the aesthetic is so hideous that it'd be
pretty easy to get this wasteland
confused without world you know where
the bad guys live can the combat squad
over here just like drive in a town and
pick up some groceries once in a while
just so we can see that other people
exist and with most 90s kidz shows the
characters now have been morphed into a
bunch of hyperactive angsty teenagers
judging by the youth and their designs
and voices Raiden has portrayed more
like his movie counterparts so he's kind
of sarcastic and jokey give me a break
Jax you know I can't fight your battles
for you why not some time when the world
isn't about to be invaded outdraw you
gret liu kang and sonia is boring as
cardboard so this is the most comic
accurate casting yet Nightwolf is a tech
nerd who runs all the bases computers
because that makes sense
curtis strikers io gives a [ __ ] sub-zero
is the moody angsty quiet guy I guess
yeah that guy looks Chinese nailed it
Jackson Sonya are the ones who feel most
like a couple of teens and it's just so
weird
especially Sonya her character was
jacked the hardest rather than being an
overly serious duty driven soldier she's
like a hot-headed [ __ ] that loves
punching she's extremely aggressive at
everyone for no reason we can't trust
sub-zero he's a traitor to his own clan
what why is that a downside he betrayed
his clan of evil ninjas that wanted to
turn him into a robot and strip away his
free will
oh boy I can't believe this chick
betrayed her father what a disloyal
cowards we can't trust someone like that
[Music]
something like that don't you ever call
me that
heywhat i sydney sannyas
characterization is also baffling
because she's always talking about how
much she hates fighting even though
she's the one who seems to enjoy it and
seek it out the most all we ever do is
fight we train to fight and then we
fight some more do you ever miss just
being a woman I mean with all the
fighting what kind of life is that I'm
so tired of all the fighting I feel like
this was a mandatory stipulation
instituted by the network like don't
make them love violence and punching too
much in this show almost exclusively
about that we don't want the kids to
take away a bad lesson we do Sonny I
understand I've been ready to blow
myself
the voices are hit or miss I think
having Clancy Brown and Ron Perlman two
of the best villains and animation was a
pretty solid choice but then those are
the only two sound really cool just
listen to Sektor welcome to the place
where you will buy cheese pizza I mean
at least it's cool that the cyber ninja
show up at all sir accent sector or two
of my favorites what the [ __ ] fight
scenes are pretty forgettable and they
occasionally use moves through in the
game but obviously toned down
[Applause]
scorpions spear sure ain't getting any
love today is it a weird pom vagina
snake every time
why can't he stab anyone with it oh
great Sonya has two catchphrases
this stuff is how it goes on the face
not in it I'm making a facial mask
everything about this show is close
enough to mortal combat to be
recognizable but it's just off
you gotta love how they try to put a
message in each episode like the hot
take bullying is wrong I love Jax's
tragic backstory that he was bullied for
being overweight as a kid well I was fat
I don't mean just a little pudgy either
I'm talking fat like that fattest kid in
school now the other kids used to rag on
me something fierce obesity and
unresolved emotional issues just when I
thought he couldn't get any more
American I love you Jax you're my hero
okay so jealous he's gonna bust a nut
hey give him a break he's in pain
I had to praise anything about this show
it's this one episode where Shang Tsung
is resurrected from the dead just to get
big slap
and then he goes on a crime spree that
disrupts nature and messes with Raiden's
powers I think the writing here is
genuinely pretty good Jax notices
Raiden's fears of becoming mortal again
and gives him some friendly advice
there's a lot of long conversations full
of character development for these two
and you see them grow a little closer
from just allies to actual friends I
like these characters they're
interesting but then the episode ends
and the next one is just back to the
usual crap at least there's one on
ironically good episode the animations
is fine I guess I like these geometric
simplified character designs even though
the coloring looks a little pale on the
skin tones I thought I'd hate this show
mostly from how rough the first episode
was but eventually it got passable like
it's just another generic
run-of-the-mill 90s action cartoon
designed to be a big toy commercial but
at least it was competent at being that
and I've certainly seen worse it's
exactly what you sign up for when you
click on that for our YouTube video I
suppose a Mortal Kombat TV series could
have been worse like a physic rinji
live-action show with Power Rangers
level fights a huge cast of characters
who aren't even remotely related to
Mortal Kombat awkward poor 90s
television quality CGI and fan film
level set design I'm not ready for that
let's talk about something else like um
you oh I got it what's the first thing
you think of when you imagine Mortal
Kombat what themes and ideas come to
mind positive inner growth in the desire
to help your community exactly The
Mortal Kombat live tour was a very bad
idea but boy did they commit to it
apparently this thing was selling out
theaters nationwide for a while and even
made it on the news now we have Shang
Tsung explained what Mortal Kombat is
truly about teaching kids how to read
and the wisdom and stability martial
arts can bring to your life violence has
always been around but what martial arts
and this show has to present is all
positive messages what helps children be
able to
and concern about violence to be able to
overcome any obstacles which is in their
life and be able to obtain goals it
helps them to commit to good things in
their life this helps spread awareness
and helps to overcome a literacy oh yeah
hey is that that is the ultimate 6-pack
of a stomach that's like an eight-pack
okay oh yeah these costumes are adorably
bad which is a perfect description for
our next topic it helps children be able
to can be able to mortal combat conquest
they spelled it with a c' so it's
already wrong is a show that has no idea
who it is made for and why it exists is
a pure anomaly where no one thought
about the reason they made this show or
what audience could possibly like it
it's certainly not for the fans of the
games because it isn't violent it's not
even really about the tournament itself
just some stuff that happens in the same
universe it's not for any new audience
members because every episode just
throws in random overcomplicated lore
from the games that a newcomer would
think sounds stupid it's not for kids
because there's too many boring scenes
about the main character pondering heavy
concepts and philosophy while a
sidekicks rob corpses and attempt them a
less people while under mind control
from a sorcerer who refers to his
assassins as it's not for adults because
the fight scenes and visual effects are
so laughably bad and impossible to take
seriously speak we start out with the
usual set up Raiden is groomed to
champion to save earth realm by winning
the tournament and stopping out worlds
win streak from getting a 10 so far
they've won 9 and if this evil
alternate-dimension gets to that 10th
wind the Elder Gods will allow them to
invade and enslave earth you know basic
[ __ ] except this time the hero is coming
Lau nope
that guy remember way back in part one
how he said his ancestor was a hero that
was killed by Goro like five hundred
years ago well this shows about him
prior to his change in hairstyle and
inevitable defeat being that it's five
hundred years ago none of that silly
awesome sci-fi [ __ ] like lasers and
cyborgs can show up though for whatever
reason Scorpion and sub-zero are here
despite their disagreement happening in
like the late 1980s all other characters
are ageless gods and demons so they get
a pass Kung Lao beats Shang Tsung and
saves the world pretty early on then
abandons his costume because shut up so
he goes home to earth shacks up with a
royal guard who's bad at his job and a
thief vet hey wait a minute this girl
goes on a ver head rammed through a tile
wall by Arnold Schwarzenegger what an
honor
so Lau and his two roommates are now
targets because of his win in the
tournament and just get harassed every
episode by various magical goons who
want to prove they're the best or kill
him before the next tournament which is
in 50 years let's break it down the cast
none of the main cast are exactly good
acting but they're not awful I'd say
they're on par with like a decent fan
film watch til we saw him Wilson they
hit the sea hold it just hold it what
did ray didn't say when he stood in
front of the portal to Outworld get the
hell out of here now you want us to go
back we don't have a choice things are
out of control we need raiding some
smaller characters are more noticeably
bad than others like kung Laos
girlfriend who gets frigid in the first
episode
your strength is in me
or Takeda is no more I am scorpion I was
sent to make you suffer and been good ah
not Edie Boone I kind of like the guy
they got to be Raiden and he's got
enough range that he also plays Shao
Kahn you can't even tell they're the
same dude as was the style at the time
Raiden's a sarcastic dick and I kind of
missed this version of the character not
the first guy to be given responsibility
come well maybe I don't want it tough
you've got it just like everybody else
yeah that looks like katana good job
this adaptation of Shang Tsung is pretty
campy and fun but he can't measure up to
Carrie here you keep Ogawa yeah that
looks like Molina yeah I'll give you
half a point on that one to fill for a
22-episode season this show keeps
characters from the game to a minimum
and inserts a lot of original Schmucks
who just aren't as memorable or
interesting like Shang Tsung's
girlfriend that's like basically
Starscream who he meets after getting
exiled to work in the mines for being a
loser her ghostwriters girlfriend or
quan chi's hired thug joy Turner who's
also his girlfriend also this lame-ass
guy Reiko can you imagine if any of
these awful characters were in the game
oh yeah
hey Shang Tsung and Quan Chi are
together in an episode titled close
enough pasta the show's costumes excel
when they're four characters from the
games Raiden Caan all four ninjas who
show up and Tam Quan Chi looks great
this is pretty much exactly his costume
from mk4 and mythologies it's a shame
that he's not played by rich divisio
though and that he talks like this
what was that never mind he was cool up
until he made that noise all the female
characters are dressed in what looks
like lingerie fetish gear for some
reason hot that looks cold as for
everyone else they're taking cues from
mk4 and just wearing old vaguely Asian
vaguely European vaguely Middle Eastern
just old clothing they can't decide on
an aesthetic the main heroes in
particular are all dressed like [ __ ]
cabin-boy
Showtime fight scenes they typically
suck and all feel identical like the
characters are just doing the same
handful of moves over and over in every
fight in the same few locations the plot
of each episode just dead stops so these
goofballs can heat up the running time
doing slow motion back flips and
roundhouse kicks at each other with a
very poor sound mixing
none of these hits feel like they have
any impact because they cut just before
the hit makes contact then show another
take of it closer up Jackie Chan
explains some neat stuff about fight
choreography that always stuck with me
is that when editing his own fights he
cuts just a second after the hits just
to show the reactions so the audience
can register it better from here boom
again strong change his second film the
audience just it's so quick they know
there's fighting going on they cannot
really see what's going on American
movie you can see there's a lot of
movement because the camera angle
movement that means the actor they don't
know how to fight the director used the
angle the audience is very dizzy
otherwise every time someone gets hit
that impact is in this weird nebulous
space between frames where the camera
jumps to a new place and it just doesn't
feel real the editing in general is
poorly executed a lot of time because
the blocking of the fights gets really
confusing just look at the floor here
and how between several shots it seems
like they just keep hopping to a new
place or held the lighting will change
sharply from one shot to the next and
just
feels like the character teleported
somehow I think they had the performers
run these same fights in the set
multiple times filmed it from different
angles and then just cut to whichever
angle look the best for each move which
is like how you typically shoot a
dialogue scene so the end result is the
camera just not feeling like it has any
motivation or a reason for being
anywhere here's a super far away shot
from behind them here's a super close-up
shot with shaky cam here's a top-down
view because we had a stepladder on set
that day and by god we were gonna use it
they also make no attempt to have the
actors look beat up at the end of all
this they can wail on each other for
four minutes straight and still have
perfect hair and clean untethered
clothes afterwards I've done what I came
for flawless victory
[Music]
however sometimes they pull out all the
stops and the fight choreography gets
noticeably way better
and that's when Scorpion and sub-zero
are fighting
god bless whichever a beautiful soul on
set said these two are the only reason
most people are tuning into this show we
better not screw that up
so the fights with Scorpion and sub-zero
have way better stunts way cooler
locations and a lot more impact in the
use of the environment hell even the
camera placement seems to have a little
more thought put into it if you just
autocorrect the bad CGI in your brain to
something more believable then these
fights are pretty cool hey grunkle mole
someplace ooh
say cheese in spite of everything wrong
with this show something about it just
doesn't feel cynical there's a genuine
heart and fun tone for it that may not
feel like Mortal Kombat but it's not
completely unpleasant I tried to hate
this show but I just can't it's not like
journey begins or defenders of the realm
because it doesn't feel like every
creative decision was made to sell
products or make a quick and easy buck
off the hype of this franchise sure it
doesn't feel like the love letter to the
series you'd want either but it gave an
honest attempt misguided as it may be so
maybe check it out I don't know you
don't have to if you don't wanna the
show ends with Shao Kahn killing all the
heroes and invading earth laying waste
to the village and striking down a
bloody and beaten Raiden while laughing
maniacally fun all of these examples of
the series branching out in the worst
ways really paint a great overall
picture
Mortal Kombat could have been one of the
biggest franchises of all time like it's
got enough material in the lore
characters and ideas that it could have
been on par with Marvel and DC there was
an insane amount of potential and at
every point it was squandered by people
who just wanted to use the name to
generate cash between all the hype and
controversy for the games this was a
huge name in the 90s but these days that
name has rarely said outside of talk
exclusively about the games or just the
off reference in a comedy sketch so many
times it could have elevated to a new
level and pop-culture consciousness
but so rarely did these adaptations and
tie-ins know what they were going for
either by trying to take the material
too seriously or not serious enough or
just flat-out not understanding it at
all
these examples just knock the wind out
of what could have been a giant and
caused everyone to slowly forget it was
a thing outside of the games I'm not
saying all these movies and shows and
comics would have been better if they
had Brian house level violence but by
just knowing who they were making these
things for and why it shouldn't have
been watered down and marketed to kids
and it certainly shouldn't have been so
ashamed of what made these games
memorable with all that being said you
may notice I skipped something but this
video is long enough and I think a train
wreck on this level deserves its own
video next time on Xavier Ball Z
franchise annihilation you want more you
want more palpable some mortis punk-ass
Buster just a quick reminder before you
go that I post my videos a day early on
patreon and give exclusive
behind-the-scenes content and patron
exclusive videos please consider
becoming a patron it really helps me out
if you want a more short-term way to
support the channel you can check out my
merch and the links in the description
we have t-shirts phone cases posters
mugs pillows baby onesies and so much
more see you next time
[Music]
[Music]